hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from this year's
Champions chest T finals it is ala fja
versus n abdat and it is their second
game so here they will play two rapid
games if the two rapid games are drawn
they go into Blitz Games and uh then
Armageddon depending on how many did
they draw but if anyone wins this one
then of course they win the match and
tomorrow they get a different opponent
so as this is the first game we showing
uh let's dive straight into it it's a
very very um clean line of the Queen's
Gambit and um ala employs the line that
Magnus Carlson already used against ala
uh but in a classical game in Norway
chess in 2020 but I will tell you where
the game deviates from that uh and why
is it better or worse so ala with the
white pieces opens with D4 we have D5
Pawn to C4 and E6 declining the Queen's
Gambit we have Knight to C3 and Knight
to F6 we have C captures on D5 e
captures uh and now Bishop to G5 the
so-called positional line we have Bishop
to E7 uh E3 and here nbe castles we have
Bishop to D3 and now Rook to E8 so all
standard stuff I've been played many
many times Knight GT2 preparing castles
then maybe F3 and D4 in the future if
black allows it with H6 uh Knight U uh
sorry Bishop back to G back to H4 and
now C6 strengthening the center here we
have castles and now uh Pawn to A5 this
is the first moment where the game
deviates uh in the game Magnus cross and
versus a f Norway chest 2020 Al there is
a went Knight B to D7 and it is um the
engine sort of gives Knight B to D7 and
A5 sort of the as the same strength also
uh Knight to H5 um are the top three
options so of course they both know that
and it's merely a matter of which line
you choose so A5 uh we have Rook to C1
and now Knight B to D7 and now we have
Pawn to A4 stopping Pawn to B5 and pawn
to A4 from Notre backck and here there
are a few games where Knight H5 was play
trying to trade off the dark Square
Bishop but here not goes Knight back to
B8 and it is now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game no Notre
backck now wants to REM maneuver his
Knight via the A6 square and then maybe
to B4 in the future or maybe to C7 and
E6 uh all depending on what alza plays
so Pawn to F3 controlling the Knight
also might have some E4 ideas in the
future giving up the bishop this this
diagonal also to retreat if needed
Knight to A6 and now Bishop back to F2
adding more support to the E3 Pawn
Knight to B4 attacking the bishop and
just Bishop back to B1 we have Pawn to
B6 now preparing to develop the bishop
to this diagonal H and here we have
Knight to G3 and okay Rook to A7 The
Rook can also now help out with the
defense of the center with something
like Rook D7 or Rook to E7 even go after
the E3 pawn pawn to H3 and now Bishop to
D6 clearing the path for the for the
black Rook uh we have Queen to D2 and
now Bishop back to B8 so nicely
positioning the Bishops here and you
will have to be a little bit careful if
the queen lands on C7 for example you
might get checkmated if you move the
Knight and here Ala plays Rook F to D1
Rook F to E1 does look like a move that
anyone would play uh supporting E4 but
no ala goes Rook F to D1 uh we have
Bishop to E6 and now Knight C uh to E2
REM maneuvering the Knight over at to F4
if needed then maybe to D3 to control E5
and so on uh but here we have Rook eight
to E7 piling up on that E3 pawn and Rook
to C3 already setting up a nice defense
here Knight to D7 and now we have Pawn
to E4 alza strikes in the center and
notbe Strikes uh against the center with
Pawn to C5 we have Knight to H5 now this
Knight is a very nasty attacker here and
even though it seems like Norbeck has a
lot of pieces in front of his King the
only pieces that are actually active in
the defense of the king set and by the
king set I mean one of these three pawns
are the rook and the bishop the Queen
Bishop Knight rook and the other Knight
here uh not so much so if ala can make
use of that should be a very powerful
attack D captures on e4 F captures on e4
and now uh we have Bishop to A2 going
after the light squore Bishop on B1 uh
Pro problem is if you play something
like F6 which um does give a square for
your Bishop because D5 could be a little
bit problematic then E5 even becomes an
option and let's say F captures and E5 D
captures and C5 now you have problems
here you can't move the Knight C6 uh
will be a problem and if you capture
then comes Bishop to E4 and it's a
really terrible position for black
Bishop captures on C5 is coming The Rook
also coming to G3 will be a problem with
ideas of Queen captures on H6 so the
objectively this is completely winning
for
alza so not tried a different approach
he played Bishop to A2 Bishop captures
Knight captures attacking the Rook ala
attacks the rook and now Notre Beck
shifts the Knight back to B4 but now
Knight E to G3 trying to go for this
Knight to F5 maneuver to go after G7 and
probably Notre Beck thought that that's
exactly what was going to happen so he
played Queen to C7 stopping the knight
from moving otherwise you just get Queen
to H2 but ala played a move that Notre
did not expect so feel free to pause the
video and uh win the game for alira
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
wonderful idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show Knight
captures on G7 this is what ala played
and now there's really nothing you can
do here like I said it seems like all of
these pieces are defending the black
king but they're really not none of them
are actively defending the black king
and point is uh if you let's say you
don't capture the Knight what do you
play you move the Rook you don't want to
lose the Rook uh it's it's a matter of
playing whatever any any move here will
win you you now you can't move the
Knight otherwise The Rook hangs what can
you play B cus here then the Knight
comes to F5 attacks The Rook also Queen
comes to H6 you're going to get
checkmated on G7 and if Rook to E6
preventing that then even Knight
captures on H6 check once the king moves
then Rook comes to F3 and um well yeah
you you didn't even accept the sacrifice
and already your complete um King side
is busted um so not really something to
to look for to so said all right I have
to capture it whatever happens happens
and ala play Knight to F5 with check
King to G8 and now Rook to G3 with check
now you cannot uh just move the king
whatever play if King to h8 of course
then Queen captures and H6 is Checkmate
also if King to H7 then Queen captures
is Checkmate and if you move to uh and
uh well if you move to f8 also Queen
captures on H6 is Checkmate so uh moving
the king doesn't really help you the
only thing that's left is Queen captures
on G3 this is what he played but after
Bishop captures and Bishop captures ala
just played Queen captures on H6 and he
was in this position on move 32 that not
abdat resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for ala fuja in round two of
this year's um Champion Chester finals
uh it's the round two of the first match
but yeah what a a wonderful way to win
uh like I said it it seemed like there
there were all of these pieces defending
the black king but uh you know now that
you've seen Knight captur s G7 you
realize oh literally none of my pieces
are defending the black king so yeah
that's a problem uh so very nice done by
Ala and you you resign this because
there's no defense this is Checkmate and
you play something like F6 for The Rook
to guard G7 uh then simply a nice check
we pick up the bishop here and that's
all there is to it there's not enough uh
compensation here uh you have you have
zero
compensation uh so you might try
something but still your Rook is hanging
here if Rook to F7 you're just going to
threaten Checkmate again the Knight
covers G7 and E7 and if you stop that of
course a nice nice Fork will uh take
even more material from black so this is
a you know collapsing so after Queen H6
notbe resigned and alza takes the first
match so this is only the first game and
the first match we are covering of the
Champions Chester if you have any
favorites do has suggestion as usual and
I will very happy go over the games H so
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank David gasparian
Rik shaver Albert Willer Del Nathan I
love you Dad and Milos kesich for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your uh
day